[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
et dans quelques instants nous allons
ouvrir un procès un vrai procès avec un
procureur un avocat vous serez faire le
procès de gabriel matzneff puisque la
justice ne l'a pas encore fait elle le
fera peut-être un jour les médias le
font et bien nous aussi on va le faire
mourir faire sous la forme d'un vrai
procès avec une attaque et une défense
comme au foot mais de ballon rond
d'autres d'autres sujets il y aura
évidemment la sphère carlos ghosn
il y à aussi précis de décrypter un peu
ce qui se passe sur le problème des
retraites
on parlera aussi de la sphère blackrock
est ce que le président de la république
et raison de remettre la légion
d'honneur à au président de ce fonds de
pension pour parler de tout cela jean
schram lajouanique bonjour vous êtes
éditeur on parlera peut-être en fin
d'émission de votre dernière apparition
deux pieds dedans dans quoi on se
demande
on se demande dans ces chefs-d'oeuvre de
la rentrée ça oui mais non c'est ce but
est venu d'un monde remarquée entre
matzneff et ça y'a pas photo donc voilà
il n'ya pas de député
il n'y a pas de petits enfants nous
avons le président de vous le procureur
stéphane marsan où le professeur ou le
professeur aussi professeur louis bozon
oui là vous aurez pu venir avec une robe
rouge de deux professeurs oui mais en
dehors de l'enceinte universitaire jeu
je suis assez modérée absolument cela
dit c est magnifique tout à fait oui
mais oui c'est du lapin c'est du lapin
depuis quelques années comme le gg les
avocats elles mêmes tout fout l'camp
groupe 2 mais c'est un peu une comédie
sur matière bâti neuf listes ont changé
mais il y a une avocate énoncé vous
prendre la défense de gabriel de sf
c'est donc laurent sperka du barreau de
versailles et vous allez vous acceptez
vous êtes été commise d'office au tessin
alors que nous sommes en grève
voilà donc je vais faire
tant pis je ne vais pas être solidaire
avec mes confrères pour ce procès mais
nous allons commencer peut-être par
d'autres sources
l'événement enfin l'événement médiatique
événement dont on a beaucoup parlé c'est
l'événement celle à l'évasion et la
conférence de presse de carlos ghosn
[Musique]
alors comment commandes moi je dit
carlos ghosn mais on peut dire gones ont
dit comment carlo gauche on progresse
sur la vague de chlore au début au début
tout le monde disait carlos goshn commun
et puis finalement je pense que par
facilité de langage selon la libre
carlos ghosn s'est aussi bien à carlos
ghosn
aujourd'hui voilà c'est l'anglais de
carlotto carlo ces parties fines en
japonais ont dit que c'est pour ça oui
il s'est fait la malle en japonais qui
commandait le dis pas parce que
peut-être qu'ils ont confondue avec
alors il ya plusieurs il ya plusieurs
éléments intéressants dans cette affaire
il ya d'abord ce feuilleton très
rocambolesque de l'évasion qui a sidéré
quand même tout le monde visiblement et
il l'a réuni les pédales et s'est enfui
dans une malle transporté alors sa cote
est quand même 5 millions à l'évasion
d'après ce qu'on peut savoir
oui alors il lui il ne confirme bien
évidemment parce que là mais c'est vrai
qu'on est avec carlos dans un univers
absolument abracadabrantesque
il quitte le japon en abandonnant une
caution de 12 millions d'euros comme si
nous on perd des 20 euros sap à la doua
le déranger plus que ça il fait il
s'enfuit pour 5 millions d'euros
mais on est dans des temps d dans les
hautes sphères de la de la finance et de
la fin c'est extrêmement curieux et
salerne ce qu'est personnes fin juin
après sur le personnage est totalement
déplaisant parce que c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui a passé 17 ans à nous dire
tout le plus grand bien du japon des
sociétés japonaises qui était un paradis
c'était presque un exemple c'était
merveilleux et c'est pendant que la
justice avait occupé il ne s'est jamais
occupé de savoir quel était le fond du
japon de la société japonaise ça ne
concernait pas elle était au dessus de
ça depuis maintenant ils découvrent
alors qu'il est traité comme tous les
japonais
et comme un japonais de base il est mis
en prison alors bien évidemment que le
régime judiciaire et carcéral japonais
est totalement répugnant et scandaleux
mais il est pas plus scandaleux pour un
peu carlos ghosn que pour un japonais de
base et lui ça le dérange maintenant là
dès ce matin enfin sur interview sur
france inter il il ose dire que le japon
serait pas une démocratie quasiment fin
jeudi à prague pendant 17 ans nous a
vanté ce pays
alors il se passer la statistique est
vrai mais roddick eu dans 99 %
pratiquement des cas les jugements
correspondent aux réquisitoires des
procureurs ce qui est beaucoup plus
beaucoup et en s'agissant des étrangers
c'est quasiment 100% de condamnation est
non
c'est d'ailleurs c'est le céser on peut
un peu interpréter la l'évasion des deux
fêtes de deux façons est-ce qu'on
s'évade parce que bon on est coupable ou
est-ce que ça va tu parce que on est
innocent et qu'on pense qu'on ne pourra
pas prouver son innocence et les deux
thèse sont tout à fait compatibles tout
à fait défendable l'une et l'autre oui
encore une fois la seule chose qui est
curieux c'est les paroles de carlos
ghosn qui a l'air de dire que lui c'est
pas une fuite qu'ils ne fuient pas la
justice mais il fut l'injustice passé ce
que ce que tout se passe sous son
contrôle
ce que ce que tous présumés coupables
ou présumé innocent accusé va dire j'ai
jamais vu que bien évidemment et alors
il se plaint aussi disait pas vu ma
femme mes mais qui prisonniers voit sa
femme tous les jours qui mis en
accusation à des conditions de vie à
grave il a l'air de découvrir comme ça
tout d'un coup le monde on dit ah bah
oui c'est c'est curieux je suis traité
comme tout le monde
heureusement qu'il est traité comme tout
le monde et je veux dire il était au
japon il a fait fortune au japon et baky
et qu'il assume les conséquences de sa
vie de ces choses au japon pourquoi ce
contrat d il ya peut-être un côté
psychanalytique puisqu'on apprend ce
squat c'est dans l'ope ce que son père
dans l'or serait bon que s'opère un
trafic de pierres précieuses et qu'ils
étaient accusés de meurtres mis en
prison
relâché ensuite remis en prison ensuite
pour pour trafic de faux billets de
hockey
il ya peut-être une peur de la prison
qui vient aussi de cette ascendance la
maison qui n'avait d'ailleurs jamais
parlé on peut s'inquiéter de ce que va
faire le fils de carlos à l'opération il
ya en tout cas une entreprise de
communication qui est assez redoutable à
la hauteur du personnage mécanismes de
communication dans lequel carlos ghosn
se révèle excellent communicant est
meilleur qu'il ne l'était quand il est
bien meilleur en effet qu'il n'était
lorsqu'il était aux affaires
c'est pas sans rappeler alors je sais ce
que c'est anne méaux qui est oui alors
que de la décidément
partout toujours auprès d'eux n'a pas
marché avec ryu moins bien marché avec
fillon voilà mais alors ça me rappelle
mes toutes choses étant égales par
ailleurs c'est à dire qu'en réalité ça
n'a que peu à voir mais ce qui s'était
passé avec avec strauss kahn il y avait
une espèce de de sidération et c'est
alors les conditions étaient totalement
différente etc
et puis et puis le le le la confession
de cahuzac aussi en terme de
communication alors qu'ils vont se
terminer
strauss kahn c'est fini aussi je doute
que ce soit terminé pour carlos ghosn
d'affaires carlos ghosn sait que pour
l'instant ça fait du bien on a
l'impression qu'il ya pas de volet
sexuelle à la faire et comme depuis des
années à chaque fois toutes les affaires
ya toujours un côté sexuel où là après
la pudibonderie un rifain le la aux
salaires justes c'est de la délinquance
financière pure et simple et du coup ça
fait du bien oui vous avez une vie aussi
mais aussi un succès sexuellement
c'était assez sur le rôle purement
financiers
mais les trois jeux sexuels se passe
mais mais vous avez raison de rappeler
aux fausses ozcan
cahuzac parce qu on est dedans c'est
peut-être ça qui provoque un peu
l'intérêt la sidération
c'est la chute des puissants il ya bien
sûr la chute des puissants enfin une
chute deux puissants c'est à dire que en
effet n'importe quel quidam n'a pas les
moyens de s'évader dans une malle avec
des jets privés
c'est une chute depuis un an laissant en
effet comme vous l'aviez une caution de
2 millions enfin c'est pour le personnel
a dit à tout le monde n'a pas des allées
un réseau aussi incroyable que lui pour
pouvoir avoir des relais et pouvoir
partir au delà de la sphère c'est quand
même un rocambolesque est assez amusant
ce fonds dit d'ailleurs que new line
enfin toute une série lui lui précise
qu'il y en a d'autres
d'autres sociétés de production de films
qui sont intéressés et évidemment par
cette histoire d'évasion plus que par le
parlement
les comptes de renault s'il est bien
fait assez formidable d'ailleurs il ya
des oss 117 ans là c'est incroyable
il ya des hommes de main ça
extraordinaire qui ont participé
visiblement à cette évasion il ya
quelques pilotes qui sont un peu embêtés
g20 compris l'on puisse enfin plus ou
moins embastillant turquie ce qui doit
être à peu près aussi sympathique que
d'être embastillé au jardin donc là
c'est donc quand on entend carlos qui
dit oui je veux pas raconter ce que je
mets deux personnes dans l'embarras ya
déjà pas mal de gens qui sont dans
l'embarras canon qui est belle une
notion assez auprès des agences les
avocats japonais parce que ses avocats
étaient à bas ils sont malins ils
séquestraient les passeports puisqu'il
avait à trois passeports dont qu'il
séquestrait les passeports il s'était
porté garant de ce qu'il resterait dans
son domicile et que l'assignation à
résidence serait respectée donc c'est un
peu compliqué pour quoi
mettez-vous en grès le soutien de
charles
après il ya le volet industriel qui est
intéressant aussi parce qu'il a l'air de
dire que aujourd'hui renault est en
difficulté que l'alliance nissan renault
ça c'est vrai koné des contrecoups
terrible d'en tirer
en fait il a l'air de dire que personne
n'a été à la hauteur
quand on veut succéder il expliqué que
renault je sais pas si c'est vrai ou pas
que renault perdrait 20 millions par
jour jours en bourse aurait un petit peu
de mal à gaza qui dit les 11 millions à
côté
s'il est aussi brillant que ça je suis
un peu étonné parce que on construit pas
une voiture on ne la conçoit pas en dix
minutes
donc ça fait un peu plus de 14 mois
qu'il n'est plus à la tête de renault
et là tout d'un coup ce sera la
catastrophe alors qu'une voiture ça se
prépare 15 ans à l'avancement tous tous
prennent part je ne sens pas le de la
stratégie d'entreprise des liens avec
nissan du ratage du ratage du day 2 de
l'accord avec fiat qui l'a fait
finalement avec peugeot alors que dit-il
huile leur et mener à bien tous étaient
pratiquement fait tout ça paraît un peu
rapide et puisse de jeu je rappelle
aussi que l'air carlos ghosn c'est quand
même le type qui a laissé s'évader entre
guillemets son numéro deux carlos
tavares pour prendre la direction du
principal concurrent peugeot
donc je verrai si génial soit-il il
aurait pu le faire signer peut-être un
contrat de de non-concurrence peut-être
que les autres valeurs en vue d'être
numéro un
bah oui oui mais sympa les gars ont su
placer un dôme et ça se gère encore une
fois être un grand patron c'est ça aussi
alors je dire et fils à faire de
l'espionnage et 10 ans gagne
3 une espèce de rhétorique tellement
tellement commune d'une espèce de manque
d'humilité et de toujours la faiblesse
de se croire indispensable
c'est un philosophe charentais disait
t'es maritime disait on succède à des
incompétents et on est remplacé par des
ingrats celle ci je vois la baule me
fait penser exactement cinq charentais
et puis y'a pas sport charentais aussi
je ne sais pas mais c'est il ya el rey
7,7 il de l'intérêt de beaucoup de
producteurs de films
elle est assez intéressante parce qu'au
fond on est allé limite la fiction de la
réalité quoi on voit bien pourquoi on
est intéressé par ça ouais enfin si tout
est possible enfin c'est marrant quand
on est dans un monde où tout est
possible c'est à dire quand un pdg qui
s'évade ça devient un film quoi et bien
une fiction mais il est vrai qu on al
impression un peu que tout fout l'camp
vous ne trouvez pas bon on a fait le
tour de voir on a fait le tour sur mon
aventure oui oui
l'épisode les pistes où je rêve je rêve
que les services secrets nippon enlève
carlos ghosn ou liban comme aurait pu le
faire les services secrets israéliens
mais là on se dise ça sort et de la
forêt de la gueule ça redorer l'image du
du japon mais alors peut-être que c'est
pas non plus et chemin mais non besson
alors on va passer maintenant l affaire
madoff
et ça va être le procès
[Musique]
j'en cherche peut-être commencer
peut-être avec vous alors je dis tout de
suite que vous avez accepté de jouer
stéphane mans sont le rôle du procureur
je vois là et fluence marcadet par
principe la fin ça c'est votre métier
le rôle de l'avocate défendront jouer
gabriel matzneff peut-être avec un mot
avec vous d'abord jean salle parce que
vous l'avez connue absolument j'ai pas
tout jeune rassurez-nous à l'époque des
à l'époque des nouvelles littéraires oui
où tout le monde était séduit et emballé
par ce personnage de dandy plutôt
élégant voilà remonte maintenant des
photos de lui il ya plus de 80 ans mais
j'adhère à trois ans à l'époque des
faits qui m'ont lui reprochent notamment
avec 7
cette jeune femme il en avait une 5
il avait 50 ans il était il portait beau
et élégant il s'exprimait bien et puis
c'est vrai qu'il a il a plutôt une belle
plume
alors après le problème c'est que je
pense que peu de gens ont lu vraiment la
totalité de ses écrits et que voilà est
ce que tout le monde a lu les passages
incriminés où il se vante effectivement
de 2,2 relation avec des deux très
jeunes enfants
peut-être pas j'ajoute juste aussi que à
l'époque ça ça ne choque visiblement
même les quelques personnes qui avaient
dû lire ça choquait assez peu de monde
alors je veux pas du tout m'acharner sur
cohn bendit que je trouve par ailleurs
très sympathique mais mais à la même
époque une émission de télévision on
voit cohn bendit un sourire jusqu'aux
oreilles qui dit tout le plaisir qu'il a
ce faire déshabiller par un garçon de 5
ans bon placé mais peut-être qu'on en
reparlera tout à fait faire glacer
non mais c'est vrai qu'il ya eu dans
l'après 68 toute une théorie de
libération sexuelle qui disait justement
c'est la bourgeoisie qui empêche les
enfants d'avoir accès à la sexualité il
faut les libérer donc il faut leur
apprendre très jeune la sexualité
qui pas tout à fait là les états
d'ailleurs de bakiev lui c'est plutôt le
plaisir qu'il avait avec des filles
garceau et c'est vrai que peut-être que
là aussi les temps ont changé c'est à
dire qu'à l'époque où on entendait
plutôt la parole du prédateur et
qu'aujourd'hui on est plutôt enclin
entendre la parole des victimes
et après il faut quoi avant de laisser
la parole à deux des éminents mais bon à
prendre
je trouve curieux ne le fait que tout le
monde le laisse tomber à terre que tous
les gens qui est client mail et plus
grand bien là il ya plus personne alors
bon oui les gens des émissions
littéraires regrette de l'avoir invité
quand même côté oui les mêmes c'est ça
qui l'ont recensé elle le laisse tomber
aujourd'hui gallimard 9 lipton suivent
son journal
ça leur est qu une sorte de lâchage des
nains charge enfin la seule vraiment
respectable dans toute cette affaire
c'est denise bombardier qui s'était à
l'époque ému de 2 les canaris belle qui
est à l'époque s'est fait très disposé
mais arrêter ma liberté à l'époque le
malheur veut dire c'est c'est pas bien
dans un canada vous seriez condamné et c
est bon et elle elle est cohérente
depuis depuis 30 ans alors que tous les
autres qui l'ont encensé sont là alors à
l'époque je rappelle et puis après on va
aurait côté vos arguments des uns et des
autres je rappelle donc gabriel matzneff
écrivain qui a écrit un certain nombre
de romans dci un essai qui s'appelle les
moins de 16 ans dont le titre dit quand
même bien les choses un certain nombre
de romans dans lequel il raconte ses
amours avec des jeunes filles de moins
de 20 qu'il n'avait pas la majorité
sexuelle qui a été donc un écrivain ans
on sait pas ce que c'est un bon styliste
il faut dire qui est aujourd'hui lâché
de toute barde que gallimard 2000 plus
que les gens qui l'ont sens et lâche un
peu donc j'ai juste une petite précision
de parler de roman
si c'est un roman ça me gênerait pas ce
sont des journaux des réseaux voilà
parce qu'un roman roman est allé de
j'espère qu'on peut continuer à écrire
ce qu'on veut et toutes ses pertes mais
quand on met ce journal et quand on met
récit là c'est différent je trouve alors
on va commencer évidemment par
l'accusation
c'est donc à vous monsieur le procureur
manceau ses professeurs mais merci
patiné sur la pour le jeu oui oui oui
merci patrice finalement mon rôle n'est
pas simple parce que je ne cache pas que
il aurait été plus confortable pour moi
d'être à la place de m mercadet choqué
par ce que il ya finalement beaucoup
plus de mon point de vue de billes pour
la défense qu'il n'y en a pour pour la
poursuite et l'accusation
mais je sens sans s'attacher uniquement
aux aspects juridiques qui vont très
vite lassé notre auditoire
je crois qu'il ya 2
de deux grandes questions il ya un
écueil impérativement à éviter me
semble-t-il dans la condamnation qu'on
peut appeler à destination de massenet
cet écueil c'est ça consisterait à
apposer qu'une époque va juger l'autre
et je crois qu'il faut extraire
impérativement la question personnelle
qui concerne l'individu le citoyen le
justiciable non justiciables matzneff de
son oeuvre et de l'époque dans laquelle
il a produit cette oeuvre
vous avez raison de souligner moi j'ai
réécouté non pas pour les besoins de
cette émission je les fais il ya déjà
plus d'un mois en replay sur le site de
france culture l'émission une émission
qui doit dater de 1976 où 77 une
excellente émission à laquelle michel
foucault était conviée gel foucault qui
philosophe un très grand philosophe
alain des migrants esprit du xxème
siècle mondialement connu et qui
argumentait à l'époque en faveur ça a
été dit ici de du développement de la
sexualité des enfants
j'ai relu aussi là le biais de la
pétition qui avait été publiée dans les
grands quotidiens de l'époque pour
défendre en effet trois pédocriminels
qui était à l'initiative de maths à
l'initiative de ma 19 lui-même qui était
jugé d'ailleurs devant les juridictions
vers cette version le ciel bleu et on y
voit là aussi des signataires éminent
parmi lesquels outre simone de beauvoir
et jean paul sartre je passe sur roland
barthes par roland barthes je passe sur
bernard kouchner et jack lang que je ne
classe pas dans la même catégorie mais
on y va aussi la signature de françoise
dolto qui a
sinon inventé du moins développés la
pédopsychiatre lise etc
c'est beaucoup énormément de parents et
de praticiens
donc il s'agissait en effet d'une autre
époque il s'agissait d'un autre temps il
s'agissait d'un autre débat que celui
qui nous occupe aujourd'hui à savoir est
ce que les enfants ont une sexualité ou
pas est-ce qu'un adulte peut à l'époque
on disait aider un enfant à découvrir sa
propre sexualité c'est en ces termes là
qui aujourd'hui sont très choquants mais
qui je crois ne doivent pas entrer dans
le débat parce que tout est extrêmement
éminemment fragile dans ce dans ce dans
cette considération la bonne époque
peuvent être trompés une époque peut
s'être trompé et nous peut-être que nous
ne serons pas présents ayant la mode
esprit de aussi de reconnaître que
peut-être que dans quarante ans quand on
nous entendra dire certaines choses on
sera infiniment choqué ce qu'il faut
donc distinguer c'est ce contexte cette
époque de l'homme lui même alors loeb
lui-même en revanche il n'est autre
qu'un pédocriminels un pédocriminels qui
déjà émettre mercadet vous l'avez
souligné qu'ils auraient dû être sinon
condamnés du moins poursuivi déjà à
l'époque parce que il me semble que
l'incrimination d'atteintes sexuelles
en gros elle si je gens croient ce que
j'ai lu il ya longtemps
elles datent en gros 2
de l'époque de l'ordonance de 45 sur la
protection des démineurs
et puis elle s'est poursuivie enfin
depuis donc déjà au moment où les faits
ont été commis
revendiquer des faits duquel à partir
desquels le mas nef à tirer profit à
tirer notoriété ces faits étaient déjà
répréhensible et on peut s'interroger
sur les raisons pour lesquelles la
justice le parquet l'est parquet se sont
abstenus de poursuivre à l'heure même et
sa gelée lully à peu alors même que le
dimas nef a été à plusieurs reprises
entendu par les services de police des
protections etc
des complicités très probablement donc
l'homme lui même me semble-t-il
il est il l'est plus juridiquement parce
que les faits sont prescrits
il est l'effet quick on connaît pour
l'instant à peut-être mais pour
l'instant c'est c'est sur le fondement
de ces faits là au delà du droit alors
et et sans y mettre de la morale parce
que je crois qu'il faut jamais jamais
mélanger les deux et fort heureusement
mais il ya ici une une
un aspect qui me paraît de toute
évidence extrêmement condamnable alors
peut-être que c'est trop évident mais en
tout cas ça doit emporter me semble-t-il
la conviction 7,7
ces agissements personnels qui déjà à
l'époque était profondément
répréhensible et vous avez appelé à
l'époque l'homme c'est l'homme et encore
une fois on en a déjà parlé ici il
convient jusqu'au bout de distinguer
l'oeuvre de lutter
vrai bien elle est ce qu'elle est alors
c'est vrai que c'est un côté sans doute
un peu gênante de distinguer entre le
journal est le roman mais finalement
pourquoi pas sa plume
vous l'avez dit moi je n'ai jamais lu de
aucun de ces ouvrages mais sa plume est
apparemment plaisante
donc continuons encore à distinguer
entre entre l'oeuvre et l'homme mais
l'homme lui l'oeuvre n'est pas
condamnable l'hommelet en poche
la parole est à la défense m monsieur le
président je vote monsieur le procureur
n'a pas grand chose dans son dossier
finalement puisque il a fait en gros il
a fait les trois cas ma plaidoirie par
rapport à loeb ce monsieur fille donc je
vais être très courte finalement vous
dites monsieur le procureur qu'il faut
distinguer l'oeuvre de l'homme j'en suis
parfaitement d'accord et vous dit aussi
qu'il faut distinguer l'homme de
l'époque
et là je ne peux pas vous suivre car on
ne peut pas dire qu'un homme ne fait pas
partie d'une société qu'un homme évolue
hors sol et or d'une époque
dès qu'il est unique détacher de la
société de l'époque c'est totalement
faux puisque il faut pouvoir lorsqu'on
est dans un procès pénal
on juge un homme mais un homme dans son
contexte un homme dans son histoire est
un homme dans son environnement que ne
peut pas détaché lorsque l'on juge cet
homme en matière pénale il faut pouvoir
pour condamner quelqu'un rapporté deux
éléments premièrement est ce qu'il y a
des faits délictueux ou criminel et
deuxièmement est ce qu'il y a une
intention délictuelle ou criminelle de
la part de la personne qui est jugé en
toute conscience donc de connaître
hakima à l'époque effectivement les
faits qui ont été commis par mon client
étaient condamnables et pouvait être
parfaitement poursuivi puisque il a eu
des relations amoureuses et sexuelles
avec des jeunes filles et des jeunes
garçons qui avaient moins de 15 ans
puisque la majorité sexuelle était à 15
ans elle est
jours quel est son intention son
intention c'était d'avoir des relations
avec avec des jeunes sans les
contraintes sans apporter la moindre
violence à leur égard
et au vu et au su de tous les acteurs de
la société
il était invité par des journalistes sur
des plateaux dans lesquelles il exposait
ses journaux et ses écrits qui ne sont
pas ni fiction puisque il racontait sa
vie ce qu'il faisait
les journaliste bernard pivot en tête
qui aujourd'hui vient dire que
finalement c'était pas si claires et que
certains journalistes regrettaient de
l'avoir invité de l'avoir interrogé en
sachant et en glorifiant entre
guillemets ses actes il y avait des
lecteurs qu'ils étaient informés les
éditeurs en premier lieu aussi étaient
informés de ce qu'ils aient dit m les
certains parents dont la mère de vanessa
voilà elle était parfaitement formés en
plus elle était dans l'édition elle
l'invitait à sa table laisser sa fille
partie remis au coeur chine pendant
lequel elle mis en garde
c'est donc ce que j'ai mis en garde kiev
oui enfin là mis en garde sa fille et
emma était mineure elle pouvait faire
plus que de la mettre en garde
elle pouvait aussi déposer plainte dès
lors que sa fille était mineure ce
qu'elle n'a pas fait donc à l'époque
toute une partie de la société certes
élitiste était parfaitement informé et
comme vous le disiez la justice aussi
étaient informés justice a fermé les
yeux les oreilles et la bouche et n'a
rien fait malgré les enquêtes de police
donc si la justice n'a rien fait c'est
probablement et vous dites il faut
détacher sa de l'époque
enfin la justice elle était dans une
époque dans laquelle elles pouvaient
parfaitement le poursuivre et le
condamner sur des faits puisque il avait
des relations avec des mineurs qui
n'avait pas cette fameuse majorité
sexuelle mais cette époque comme vous le
dit
il y avait toute une catégorie de
personnes qui mettait en avant les
bienfaits entre guillemets de ses
relations entre des adultes et des
jeunes mineurs en premier lieu vous
l'avez cité françoise dolto qui
considérait que l'enfant qui avait des
relations sexuelles avec un adulte
consentant était parfaitement légitime
et normal qu'un père qui avait des
relations avec sa petite fille ou son
petit garçon c'était une façon de lui
montrer à quel point l'amour pouvait
être formidable et de lui dire qu'il
l'aimé quand même un peu surprenant et
elle a même déclaré dans un entretien à
la revue choisir la cause des femmes en
1979 que lorsqu'un adulte demande à un
jeune jones un mot un jeune garçon s'il
veut avoir des relations sexuelles
et si l'enfant l'acceptent à partir du
moment où il y à un consentement de
l'enfant mais il n'y a pas de problème
donc on ne peut pas nier cette réalité
de l'époque dans laquelle ils évoluent
est et dans laquelle il vivait et il
n'était pas le seul à être dans cette
dans cette configuration puisque vous
avez jean genet vous avez andré gide
vous avez roger peyrefitte vous avez
tony duvert qu'ils aient eu un prix
médicis en 1973 c'était quand même
michel foucault qui a écrit quand même
sur les sexualités parallèle les
périphériques
vous avez vous l'avez cité cette lettre
de sartre et simone de beauvoir et
michel foucault en 1970 sur ca
pédophiles qui était jugé
donc on se retrouve aujourd'hui dans
effectivement une autre époque un autre
regard et puis un basculement avec toute
une mouvance depuis le début des années
2000 sur la mise en avant de la parole
de l'enfant et la parole des victimes
mais pour autant il faut se re situer
quand même dans cette époque on en pense
effectivement aujourd'hui beaucoup de
mal alors qu'à l'époque on n'en
pensaient peut-être un peu plus de bien
du moins au niveau
des élites des intellectuels et excusez
moi de le dire mais ce programme est de
la justice également puisque
manifestement enfin clairement elle m'a
rien fait et c'est bien pour ça que les
faits sont prescrits
ils sont prescrits parce que tout le
monde savait mais personne n'a rien fait
il n'y a eu aucune plainte de la part
des victimes d'alors des victimes
étaient mineures dont elle pouvait pas
déposé plainte
mais les parents n'ont pas déposé
plainte les éditeurs on continue à
éditer il a eu le prix renaudot renaudot
en 2013 il a encore dit et pardon régler
c'est oui mais en 2013 en 2010 cet avis
tient bien sûr à gallimard stock et sara
lee dit l'éditeur piste maintenant on
est tombé dans un monde de l'hypocrisie
totale de la part de tous ceux ces bons
penseurs de l'époque de saint germain
des prés qui lui tournent le dos
maintenant en disant tout des horreurs
sur lui alors qu'il avait soutenu et
qu'il l'avait fréquentée
donc les faits à mon sens ne sont pas
établies quoi que vous disiez ne sont
pas établis dans l'intention qu'avait
mon client
à ce moment là et je pense que monsieur
le président vous ne pouvez que la
quitter je ne veux pas ses deux neveux
de jugement mais il ya une chose
possible pour venir ceux que vous avez
cités par être contente absolument non
c'est quand vous dites oui c'était au vu
et au su de tout le monde c'est à dire
un pédophile aujourd'hui sa première
intention de se cacher de ce qu'il fait
et c'est vrai que là on peut pas on peut
pas dire de match steve qui se cacher de
ses actes pour le moins une même ligne
et même le contrat ils sont vantés les
écrivais et donc à libéraux sont mauvais
mais pas d'autres à l'époque
florentin tout à fait raison si si les
gens c'était totalement différent parce
que sinon gabriel matzneff n'aurait
jamais écrit récit il n'aurait jamais
caché d'amour au mans où il aurait adoré
aucun problème et pour en revenir aussi
à ce que florent seul disait c'est que
dans le 19 décembre 2019 donc il ya à
peu près moins d'un mois dans le point
il ya une chronique papier de jérôme
grimpé de jérôme béglé dit le plus grand
bien le grand dernier tout mouvement du
journal de gabriel belmont sommes le 19
décès 2019 donc j'étais quand il dit
cela c'est sympa sinon il est dû ce
papier fait tomber dessus
après quoi faire quoi déclencher une
taxe qui dit tout le monde glisse donc
on comprend bien si le 19 décembre 2019
on dit le plus grand bien de gabriel
matzneff comprend bien que quelques
piques mais tout le monde tout
maintenant tout le monde dit du mal mais
mais jusqu'à la sortie du bouquin tout
le monde dise pas oui madness et bien
personne ne serait là on apprend qu'il a
un appartement de la ville de paris
depuis trente ans ederson choqué
personne
jeffren rien était choquant donc tout
d'un coup jérôme béglé s'est s'impliqué
d'allocation des du centre national d
une ampleur mais là tout le monde
voudrait le dégrader cette fusion va pas
l'emmener en place de grève pour lui
arracher ses vêtements le flash et
s'essaye à côté mais pour revenir 10 et
stéphane ont senti le changement
d'époque
il ya en effet alors après peut-être
qu'on peut aussi porter des jugements
sur les époques et lui il ya quelque
chose qui est choquant enfin et qui
moins chaud qu'aujourd'hui c'est que à
l'époque on n'écoutait que la parole de
ba snef que qu'aujourd'hui on puisse
écouter la parole de vanessa spain gora
et des gens qui ont été les victimes est
content quand on voit et très
probablement les ravages que ça ça peut
causer dans la vie de ces jeunes
personnes qui étaient jeunes à l'époque
des faits c'est un peu comme dans
l'arène steinseltz et c'est quand même
très important d'écouter cette parole et
ses ravages sont ses ravages
psychiatriques sont réelles raisons
réelles mais six ans a été un peu voilà
tous les légumes frais enfin comme vous
le soulignez enfin c'était pas la
question de la question de la parole de
ces de ces mineurs n'étaient pas prises
en compte parce que je ne serait ce que
parce qu'on les considérait pas comme
les victimes
aujourd'hui la parole de la victime
depuis déjà assez longtemps il est bien
mieux et bien plus prises en compte et
c'est heureux mais ce ne sont pas ce
n'était pas à l'époque ces jeunes
n'étaient pas des victimes rick enfin
écouter le 7 sept
le replay de cette émission c'est c'est
complètement édifier et ce seul c'est
même une question c'est même pas une
question ni de moeurs ni culturelle pour
moi c'est à l'époque une question
politique tout à fait considérer que les
enfants des adultes puissent entre
guillemets éveiller la sexualité des
enfants c'est-à-dire de mineurs de moins
de 15 ans c'est une question politique
je ne sais plus si c'est foucault je ne
sais plus quel sont les autres invités
mais l'un des participants à l'émission
dit au fond être du côté de la famille
patriarcale papa maman les enfants etc
c'est être du côté des flics et non pas
des gros réactionnaire et nous on
voulait pas être du côté des lignes
donc c'est un bel un magnifique amalgame
une espèce de rhétorique tu es
complètement folle
mais c'est en ces termes là que des
grands esprits de l'époque raisonnée qui
l'est c'est un peu la thèse de
l'histoire de la sexualité de fukui
office qui lire la bourgeoisie dimanche
et aux politiques la dimension de l'île
de glace absolument qu'ils se retrouvent
dans une position des choses alors ce
qui est quand même
aussi étonnant c'est qu'il y a je sais
plus c'était un an ou deux ans il ya un
projet de loi qui avait été proposé à
l'assemblée nationale qui était de dire
où c'était pas un projet de loi c'était
ça avait été poussé par peut-être par un
par un je ne sais plus je me rappelle
que commence à cet effet mais où il
était débattu le fait que hand sur les
sur les mineurs de moins de 15 ans il y
avait une présomption de non
consentement et sanaa ce n'est pas passé
s'est pas passé et ça n'est pas passé
alors que enfin je veux dire oui
aujourd'hui on peut imaginer qu'un
enfant n'est pas un cas très de quatre
présents ou 14 ans on a pas de
consentement et parce que c'était au
sujet d'un processus mais le non
consentement mais en tout cas que je
crois que j'étais au sujet d'un cuir
c'est qui ceux qui étaient à pontoise
d'ailleurs je sais plus ce que ça a
donné
sur 100 sur un enfant de 11 et la
personne avait été relaxée je crois oui
il me semble à partir de là qu'il y
avait eu ce projet de non consentement
sous 15 ans mais il ya une chose qui est
assez paradoxal aussi dans cette affaire
c'est le succès apparent du livre de
vanessa spring or fer que je me demande
quelle est la motivation de l'acheteur
de ce genre de bouquin commandant koné
concurrence pour l'eau de vie des noms
qu'on écoute mais voilà mais qu'on
écoute vanessa springer à dire tout le
mal qu'elle a qu'elle a vécu toute sa
peine et tous les dommages suis d'accord
mais le livre est quand même assez cru
et raconte comme cette passion qu'elle a
vécu qui ne nie pas d'ailleurs avec
ivresse fx d'art dont il ya un côté un
peu
pas exactement quels voeux littéraire
voilà j'étais là bas c'est quand même
une histoire d'une passion entre une
jeune femme de 15 ans est à présent 13
14 de 13 jusqu'à avec un titre de 50 ans
et je trouve curieux se ce goût du
public envers bella va nous raconter
tout ce qui lui est demandé de faire
tout ce qu'il a fait c'est passionnant
et c'est alors d'un côté le lecteur est
passionné puis de l'autre côté il juste
que le type on devrait dû couper la tête
parce que tout ça c'est curieux ce
bonbon les motivations existante et que
chacun puisse les identifier l'animation
y avait il y avait je reviens justement
ce débat entre le droit la morale etc
lisez l'avocate de weinstein dit jeudi
pas de bouclier on n'est pas un pêcheur
parce que vous êtes à dugny on parle
beaucoup de religions mais c'est pas
pour ça que juridiquement il ne peut
être condamné et c'est vrai qu'il ya
aussi un peu de confusion souvent entre
la morale le droit et le l'idée que
parce qu'une chose est condamnable
moralement elles devraient être
condamnés juridiquement il faut rappeler
que c'est pas forcément le cas
évidemment la morale c'est léo ferré
disait ce qu'il ya dans merde avec la
morale c'est que c'est toujours celle
des autres et c'est sans doute pas faux
mais la morale et sans doute fin est
incontestablement pas une source mais
une une inspiration de l'ordre juridique
à un moment donné c'est dans un lieu
d'être fondements mêmes dont l'un des
fondements mai
en heureusement que le droit s'est
émancipé et continue de s'émanciper de
la morale parce que ce sont deux choses
qui sont bien qu'ils sont bien
différentes les les procès en immoralité
ne présente pas les garanties des
procédures applicables en droit ne
serait-ce que voilà voilà ne serait ce
que pour cet argument là il faut
distinguer les espèces que ces palais
depuis sa façon d'être léo ferré est ce
que quelqu'un se rappelle une chanson
qui s'appelle petit oui réentendue à
l'occasion leur est entendue parce que
elle et cette chanson dit enfin voila
c'est un type qui est amoureux d'une
fille est très petit et kirti regrette
participaçoes il veut dire qu'en chute
survenue souvient bien des paroles quand
sous ta robe il n'y aura plus le code
pénal
oui oui oui qu'ils appellent leurs
chansons de ce mois je me suis acceptée
comme à l'époque j'avais un peu choqués
par cette chanson mais c'est la preuve
aussi que l'époque des tdt pas la même
et qu'on pouvait dire des choses qu'on
pourrait lui dire aujourd'hui
est ce que je sais pas après on pourrait
dater mais il me semble que l' affaire
dutroux inconsidérée de constituer un
avant et un après mais peut-être que oui
ces programmes mais salue un
retentissement terrain enfin d'ailleurs
ce n'est pas du troll
oui oui et non parce que c'est à dire
oui oui du trou enfin c'est sordide vais
frire des jeux jusqu'au bout c'est le
sordide au carré bon certes eux
attendons la suite de cette affaire abah
passons à un actuel des clips pas très
drôle
décidément
[Musique]
alors ya plusieurs manières de parler
alors on peut parler de ce qui se passe
c'est lé conflit qui n'en finit pas ça
fait combien une quarantaine de jours de
grève on voit pas très bien la solution
chacun a ses terres de rester sur sa
position le gouvernement voit les
syndicats il faut le gouvernement
personne n'ose entend enfin bon on
pourrait parler ça mais on peut parler
indéfiniment et puis on peut être
démentie par l'actualité du jour au
lendemain il y avait autre chose qui
m'intéressait peut-être un peu plus
c'est un livre de spécialisation d'âge
qui s'appelle jérôme sainte-marie qui
s'appelle le bloc contre bloc et qui au
fond les ratios au fond les conflits de
la société actuelle c'est vrai que la
droite et la gauche ne sont plus
structurant mais quand tu es bloc contre
bloc qui parle de france est un peu ce
que disait raffin la france d'en haut et
la france d'en bas
est-ce que qu'est ce que disent
qu'est-ce que vous êtes partager cette
analyse
oui mais je trouve qu'elle est un peu
elle est un peu facile cette analyse
parce que cette cette france d'en haut
cette france d'en bas alors c'est
extrêmement maladroit d'avoir qualifié
ça de cette manière là de la part de mai
cette france là elle existe elle existe
social dans l'écho d'un peuple aux
militaires naturel voulez rire ah bon
une élite il y en a toujours
de toute façon alors quelle quelle
qu'elle soit quelle que soit sa
configuration et sa légitimité
mais on a toujours y compris dans des
dans l'histoire dans des régimes qui se
sont qualifiés eux mêmes de super
égalitaire bons jeunes communistes y
avait une élite dans les régimes
fascistes
il y avait une élite et c'est bon il y
en a eu dans la démocratie aussi mais je
c'est un peu facile parce que tout cela
n'a rien de nouveau ce kit ce qui est
neuf en revanche c'est ce sont les
modalités de l'est vecteur d'expression
de ces deux blocs et ses vecteurs
d'expression avec les bouleversements de
de la géographie politique c'est vecteur
d'expression ils sont ont endommagé
pourquoi parce que la république en
marche a plus ou moins absorbés d'un
côté la social démocratie avec ce
qu'était ce qu'a été pendant 40 ans le
parti socialiste dont il se dit d'epinay
alors qu avait un peu des à l'époque des
relents révolutionnaire mais qui les a
vite perdu
et puis donner les difformités on avait
pas il s'agissait de rire baisse à 6
c'est vrai que là pour le coup autre
époque autres moeurs que c'est aussi et
puis du côté droit
les républicains 7,7 droite à la fois
bonapartiste et orléaniste que tu une
composante politique très traditionnel
de la vie politique française
elle a aujourd'hui aussi disparu donc
qu'est-ce qu'on trouve à gauche de la
république en marche la france insoumise
ce qui reste du parti communiste est
donc une extrême gauche extrêmement
forte
enfin compte pas extrêmement forte mais
qu'on entend beaucoup plus et puis
qu'est-ce qui reste à droite le national
populisme
donc ça donne en effet une spectacle qui
est extrêmement radical avec deux blocs
qui par la voix de ses extrêmes
s'exprime en des termes différents de ce
qu'ils pouvaient trouver possibilités
d'expression dont il disposait avant le
bouleversement de l'échiquier politique
c'est une explication qui n'explique
peut-être pas tout mais qui je crois est
un symptôme de ce2 de 7,2 de ce duel au
fond de cette dualité évidemment n'a pas
disparu le nouveau monde n'a pas fait 10
passes pour aller tout à fait dans votre
sens en fait c'est une vision et c'est
le procureur
annoncé tout le jeu non mais il ya un
vide des institutions dont vite des
institutions politiques puisqu'il n'y a
pas d'autres qui arrivent partout de
l'offre politique
oui mais attendent mais dont l'institut
de la représentativité maintenance de
leur présentation
oui le conflit des gilet jaune quand
même c'est ça aussi non mais c'est
exactement cela c'est là qu'on sait que
la conséquence de ce vide d'offre
politique de ce vide des syndicats
également qu'ils ont complètement qui
sont décrochés de la base et qui
n'arrive pas à voir la base avec fait
que les gens effectivement d'un
descendre descendre dans la rue et
expriment leur mécontentement de façon
forte virulente voire violente et dès
qu'il ya un vide des institutions quel
qu'il soit par exemple dans les bourgs
lieu vite des institutions il n'y a pas
la police n'est plus là la justice n'est
plus là et dès qu'un vide des
institutions il ya des débordements et
les gens s'emparent de ce vide qui est à
dire tout à fait tout à fait logique et
sa bad en complément de ce que vous
venez de dire quand on dit tout le monde
descend dans la rue faute à le garder un
petit peu là la raison je dire tout le
monde descend dans la rue quand il ya un
million de gens qui descendent dans la
rue pour défendre l'école privée là tout
le monde descend dans la rue même le
pire épisode des idées jaune la veille à
plessala boîtier d encore arrêté mais
aussi arrêter aussi ça bon et et puis
deuxièmement bloc contre bloc
oui sûrement peut-être il ya la france
normale et puis la france et gilet jaune
ok on a on est d'accord la france qui
réfléchit lui une france qui est
de données quand même mais là en tout
cas il ya une chose c'est bien france
pour qui ça va bien pour qui sa balle
mais aussi l'espace enfin de 6,76 avec
des gilets jaunes ou à être martinez
mois moi ce que vous intéressant parce
que ce que je constate c'est que soit
disant il y aurait une france d'en bas
in france d'en haut
là il ya une france qui manifeste une
france qui peut se permettre de faire
grève parce qu'elle sait que toute façon
à la sncf ou la ratp
même si son papier des jours de grève la
boîte n'est pas en faillite ils auront
toujours leurs salaires resteront
toujours leur ticket restaurant ils
auront toujours la comité d'entreprise
il ya les mêmes gens qui gagnent moins
d'argent que le conducteur de tgv qui
est dans sa petite boutique dans sa
petite boîte qui est en train de faire
faillite parce que la france est arrêté
voilà c'est ça aussi et là on est plus
bloc contre bloc on est plus franc de
france d'en bas c'est le même pouvoir
d'achat
les commerciaux les commerces qui
ferment les petites entreprises sont
obligées de mettre la clé sous la porte
parce que le des collines arrive plus
petit et mais là le type de la sncf ou
de la ratp c'est pas son souci il peut
faire grève pendant deux mois on va le
les français sont assez bêtes pour dire
ben c'est pas grave affaire des
cagnottes
on leur donnait de l'argent millions
absolument ahurissant d'un million
d'euros dans la sueur la canade cgt ce
qui démontre aussi qu'il ya un soutien
de la part des français et il ya
toujours un soutien de la part des
français sur ces gravières monde édition
vient donc de discernement surtout des
françaises comme une cagnotte pour le
boxeur jake dont on apprend aujourd'hui
et il l'aurait frappé aussi sa femme est
à l'origine de la cagnotte
pardon c'était une base c'était une
parenthèse mais non mais c'est vrai que
là dedans il ya une ce qu'on a appelé la
crise et qu intermédiaire quand même
c'est important là qu'on le disait est
ce qu'il vaut préférer le conflit 10 et
des jaunes conflit de
avec martinez c'est que là au fond il ya
quand même cemac disais c'est une église
et c'est une bonne nouvelle un peu le
retour des syndicats quand même se jouer
entre la peste et le choléra votre
question je vais entre leur est ce que
c'est sur des zones où l'ordinaire enfin
c'est horrible si c'est ce qu'ils
pensent alors vous verrez ce qu'il faut
que ça soit structuré ou pas ce truc tu
essaies soit structuré et minc là sur ce
coup a plutôt réussi
le mais il se trouve qu'on retrouve je
pense aussi à l'intérieur des
institutions qui existent elles mêmes
cette distinction entre le syndicalisme
d'en haut et le syndicalisme de base la
base la plus indiquée la base ne subit
la base syndiquée ne suis plus
nécessairement l'écologie c'est plutôt
le lot qui suivent pas mais plutôt leur
direction des syndicats qui sont on
pourrait dire il sait bien que ça se
passe comme ça
sauf que ça d institutionnaliser un peu
ces institutions qui sur le point de
revenir
on va passer peut-être à la polémique
[Musique]
sais pas si ça vous divise beaucoup mais
ça c'est retour des choses formidables
parfois formidable danse aux comptes sur
l'épisode de blackrock alors il faut
dire un mot de ce que ces blackrock
s'éteint c'est une société américaine
qui est une
et qui est dirigée alors il ya une
branche française qui dirigé par jean
françois cirelli qui donne anciens hauts
fonctionnaires qu'ils ont c'est aussi
dirigeants de gdf suez et qui a été fait
officier de la légion d'honneur par le
président de la république et blackrock
c'est un géant de la finance est un
fonds de pension voilà c'est chercher le
mot il faut d'investissement et
évidemment comme cette remise de légion
d'honneur intervient au moment du
conflit des retraites on débat attention
alors c'est évident c'est à dire qu'on
va vers la privatisation des retraites
c'est pour ça que il m'a confessé le
président de blackrock officier de l'aln
c'est particulièrement maladroit de le
faire dans cette période là il ya un
petit copain côté soit ils se rendent
pas compte de ce qu'ils font soit
provocateur mais pour autant je ne vois
pas le rapport entre blackrock et la
réforme telle qu'elle est présentée
aujourd'hui parce que est-ce que c'est
pas aussi le rôle de préserver un public
de de favoriser des investisseurs parce
que c'est un type d'entreprise n'était
pas à six mois près cgt au gilet jaune
de décider qui doit qu'est ce qui t'a
fait qu'est-ce qu'il a fait mal ce
pauvre curé dit rien du jeu mais si vous
ramenez pas le moment je fais parce
qu'il ya un moment pour dans six mois ce
sera le moment si c'est bien c'est bien
tout le temps si c'est mal c'est mal
tout le temps n'est pas de mauvais
symbole assez bon jour on frôle celle
relation réalité du président et public
avec des fondatrices et ce que c'est se
roule pas son rôle voilà c'est ça la
barre jean aimé entendre les mêmes gens
qui râlent contre légion d'honneur au
ciré ly râler contre légion d'honneur de
me marie ange gardien je veux dire plus
des reçus si si si on est dans les
entreprises non franchement multi port
et le cuir c'est très bien c'est un
choix je veux dire on s'en fout la
france
non sauf ans haut-fourneau b ccc on
revient peut-être presque au bloc contre
bloc c'est à dire une france libérale
est une force qui nous donnera plus
jamais les gens de mer c'est un grand
patron un capitaine d'industrie parce
qu'on fonctionne un grand bâton de dix
ans ça va être payé en disant ça va être
le grand capital ou l' or lui nuit là
était aux magistrats alors il a mis des
gens en prison elle est là mais il ya un
échec final un corps à corps de gaulle
disait la politique de la france se
décide par la bourse il ya quand même
cette vieille tendance jeudi à la
politique doivent pas se mêler avec les
grands industriels
il ya il ya ce vieux réflexe quand même
est-ce qu est-ce qui est ce que c'est un
réflexe ciblant bien aujourd'hui ou à ce
qu'au contraire il faut peut-être faire
en sorte que le pays soit accueillant
pour les entreprises ou à lille je vote
pour le maire il l'a rarement été autant
mais il ya aussi un élément que j'ai lu
au cours de la semaine et que j'ignorais
avec cet épouvantail sur la fin du
système de retraite par répartition
qu'on nous dit être l'oeuvre du conseil
national de la résistance qui est faux
puisque près six mois de 1941 du régime
de vichy qu'il l'a qu'il instaurait
dirait qu'ils ont fait beaucoup de
choses mais pour autant le système de
retraite par capitalisation auquel
chaque français peut avoir accès de sa
propre volonté et par une retraite etc
concerne aujourd'hui quand même 12
millions de personnes employées sur 12
millions de salariés
lui non mais absolument déplacement des
accords d'intéressement prise de nos
biens déficit des salariés donc c'est
pas c'est pas un épouvantail et
attention on risque de dans le système
est là et l'existence de systèmes
n'empêche pas le système par répartition
d'exister être fonctionner et il n'y a
rien de choquant par rapport à la
réforme des retraites puisqu'il ya
toujours un système par répartition et
donc je vois pas le rapport entre ben et
simplement il ya une confusion qui se
fait bien évidemment dans l'été dans les
esprits mais il ya ce pays dès que
tout ce qui tout ce qui est l'industrie
tout ce qui est l'argent c'est le mal
quoi ça bah oui il ya cette idée que le
riche il faut il faut le sanctionner
c'est vrai alors qu'il faudrait enrichir
le pauvre donc démissionné le 17
merci infiniment merci florence marcadet
qui a gelé signal a perdu toute sa
retraite un peu de temps non benjamin
avait perdu l'appétit
pardon z'auraient nous sommes en grève
ou état les avocats mais les avocats
sont en a jusqu'à lundi prochain inclus
donc tout ça toute la semaine jusqu'à
lundi at-on dit il ya des perdants et
des gagnants mais on est quand même dans
les périodes est très très perdant donc
mais vous êtes soucieux de l'intérêt
général
ah ben oui l'intérêt général puisque
notre caisse apporte plus de 100
millions au régime général tous les ans
donc ils reconnaissent le pauvre
justiciables qui attend que vous veniez
le sauver de l'incarcération il attend
une semaine eh bien il va attendre une
semaine tout comme ceux qui donc
l'abattre attendent société un peu plus
gênant d'être attendant le prix donc
d'attendre eux sur la localité bercé ses
paroles gb des cibles merci de leurs
frais je dis merci vous pousse téva
d'urso merci beaucoup flore ce mercredi
et à très vite pour un nouveau prof
[Musique]